nombre de contaminations record
également aux états unis les autorités
recensent plus de 265 mille cas par jour
en moyenne sur la semaine et c'est plus
que lors de la grève de janvier dernier
cela contraint à les autorités à réagir
les précisions de notre correspondant à
washington tom abonnés le centre
américain de lutte contre les maladies a
revu à la baisse la proportion du
variant omicron dans les nouvelles
contaminations ce variant serait
responsable d'environ 60 % des nouveaux
cas de covile 19 aux états unis et puis
les autorités américaines ont également
annoncé le raccourcissement du délai à
d'isolement il est désormais établi à 5
jours pour les personnes testées
positives au co vide mais qui ne sont
pas à symptomatique et qui sont
vaccinées alors pour le moment malgré
les records en termes de nombre de
contaminations le nombre
d'hospitalisations augmente certes mais
il est encore assez loin du pic atteint
au mois de janvier 2021 ici aux
etats-unis pour l'heure les mesures de
restriction semble écartée par la maison
blanche joe biden mise surtout sur les
obligations de vaccination mais la
situation est tout de même délicate pour
le locataire de la maison blanche lui
qui avait beaucoup critiqué donald trump
lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle pour sa gestion de la
pandémie faisant de ce sujet la priorité
absolue de son début de mandat et bien à
cette semaine lors d'un échange avec des
gouverneurs joe biden a prononcé cette
phrase il n'y a pas de solution fédéral
à la pandémie laisse la responsabilité
aux états voire aux villes de prendre
des mesures sanitaires c'est une phrase
qui a été beaucoup critiqué beaucoup ont
mis en parallèle les déclarations de joe
biden en tant que candidat et les
déclarations prononcées donc cette
semaine à la maison blanche en attendant
la décision revient donc aux villes
voire aux états de prendre ou non des
mesures de restrictions sanitaires on
sait que la ville de new york par
exemple à instaurer un pass vaccinale
ces derniers jours on a pu voir des
contrôles de policiers dans des
restaurants des images qui ont provoqué
beaucoup d'émotion dans l'opinion
américaine et puis à new york il ya
toujours des manifestations contre ce
pass vaccinale justement écouter et
quelques-uns des manifestants tout le
monde à new york il doit se faire
vacciner tous ceux qui travaillent
pouvait même pas aller au travail et
subvenir aux besoins de votre famille de
votre si vous ne vouliez pas au fait de
recevoir cette injection expérimental
j'ai été exclu de mon travail je suis
exclu de la société je ne peux pas aller
dans un restaurant je ne peux pas
visiter un musée je ne peux pas et aux
événements culturels à new york
et puis la gestion de la pandémie de
kobe 19 aux états unis continuent d'être
très politique puisque l inverse des
villes démocrates comme new york des
états gouvernés par des républicains ont
décidé de modifier les conditions
d'attribution des allocations
chômage pour permettre aux non vaccinés
qui ont été licenciés d'en bénéficier et
restrictions